former new york governor andrew cuomo
who was forced to resign over alleged
sexual misconduct has now been hit with
a misdemeanor criminal complaint of
forcible touching he has repeatedly
denied harassment claims from 11 women
including current and former staffers
our national correspondent jerica duncan
looks at cuomo's growing legal trouble
andrew cuomo the former governor of new
york recently one of the most high
profile members of the democratic party
is now facing a potential criminal
charge a complaint filed thursday says
in december of last year on the second
floor of the governor's executive
mansion cuomo did intentionally forcibly
place his hand under the blouse shirt of
the victim specifically the victim's
left breast for the purpose of degrading
and gratifying his sexual desires
it was certainly not consensual although
the alleged victim listed in the
complaint has not been identified many
of the details match the story told to
us by cuomo's former executive assistant
brittany comisso in an exclusive
interview last august he
walked over shut the door
so hard came back to me
and that's when he put his hand up my
blouse and cupped my breast over my bra
in a statement camiso's attorney said
his client was surprised by the filing
of the criminal complaint but will
continue cooperating in pursuit of blind
justice i never touched anyone
inappropriately the complaint filed by
the sheriff's office is the first
criminal charge against cuomo
prosecutors must now decide whether to
move forward with the case she says it
didn't happen she says it absolutely
happened and ultimately it will be up to
the government to prove him guilty if
they can beyond a reasonable doubt
last night i spoke to cuomo's attorney
she says that the claims against the
former governor are false saying he
never assaulted anyone she believes the
sheriff's office is being motivated by
politics cuomo may have to appear in
court in november michelle all right
jerica thank you